and I said now old on a minute just one
one second you're a police officer yeah
and you're ringing me to check my
thinking yeah as I review any idea what
that makes you hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Frances Foster i'm
konstantine listen and this is a show
for you if you're bored with people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts are brilliant guests
this week is the founder of we are fair
cop Harry Miller aka Harry the owl
welcome to trigonometry thank you he say
aka Harry thou unfortunately how the owl
is no more how did the owl was was
banned from Twitter about two months ago
what did you do I called him I called
Braman stunning world champion cyclist
Rachel McKinnon poster boy and said
Strava ought to it was actually directed
at Straub and said you really ought to
check out your heroes and when they're
posting gifts of the Angel of Death
dancing up and down the grave of
Magdalene burns who's just this day died
of brain cancer I don't mean that's a
great look Strava for your poster boy so
it was the poster boy bit that got me a
lifetime ban all right so you got took
off to a great start but before we get
fully into the a story which is an
absolutely crazy one tell us a little
bit about who are you how are you where
you are how have you ended up sitting in
the chair talking to us I'm sitting in
this chair talking to you because having
posted on Twitter a few controversial
apparently conference things like I
don't believe trans women are literal
women I got a phone call I was out doing
the shopping at Tescos for my wife
because that's kind of guy I am and I
was just sitting contemplating playing
candy crush on my phone
before I went home and that's one bucket
all and I got a phone call from my
managing director at the company I work
for
it's actually my company so he works for
me and and he said H without the police
in we've had a fella called P Segal
wanting to speak to you he said I'm not
get I'm not giving him your number
because that's down to him and you but
he wants to speak to you he hasn't told
what it's about but he needs to speak to
you so here's his number okay Mikey I'll
give him a ring back so I rang P Siegel
back and said ok make what what have I
done he said ah are you Harry the owl on
social media I said yeah absolutely I am
he said ok so we've had a we've had a
complaint in from somebody down south so
right
ok you doing this is Lincolnshire right
he's not down south this is yeah but
they're very concerned about the
transgender people in your workplace I
said but as far as I know down attending
him doc I haven't got any transgender
people in my workplace so what doesn't
matter it doesn't matter you might have
and maybe you haven't got any because
you're a hateful bigot like what what
about well apparently been posting these
on social media which makes your
workplace a very dangerous place for
trans people I said let's just let's
just back up a minute here let's just
back up a minute I said have I done
anything criminal have I committed
anything criminal it's a no no you're
not committed any crime not no crime
whatsoever I said so in that case why
why are you why are you ringing me
Lucido I need to check your thinking and
I said now old on a minute just one one
second and you're a police officer
yep and your ring me to check my
thinking yeah I said have you any idea
what that makes you
so I then talk to him about George
Orwell and I said that 1984 was a
dystopian novel and not a police how-to
manual you don't think it ever heard of
George Orwell or nice thank you for well
there we go and I said so why are you
ringing me it says well in case
what you're doing escalates into a crime
that's what what what what is it that
what how could he possibly escalate into
a crime well it can do it can do and I
need to warn you that you mustn't you
must do this because if it does
escalates that could be very serious and
you're already with what you've done you
could be in big trouble from your work
from your HR department I said well I
don't know that's gonna happen because I
am the [ __ ] HR department and all the
people I employ are sensible people so
we don't have to worry about that but
again what crime is it you think I'm
about to commit and of course he talked
about Public Order offenses and he talks
about malicious communications I said
but I'm not maliciously communicated
with anybody it can't be a public order
offence because it's The Tortoise fear
I've not gone out into the street and
shouted anything so that's absolute
payton nonsense as well you know I said
a lot what's your evidence
give me your evidence I'm an
ex-policeman myself so give me your
evidence he said well I've got 30 2000
13 right yeah okay so not of them a
criminal no I said all right so in your
opinion your considered opinion which
one out of those thirty is the one that
comes closest to the line of criminality
and he was at that point he said I'm
gonna read you a limerick it wasn't even
a limerick as it turns out it was a
verse by a feminist songwriter I'd not
written it I could barely remember it
I'd all I'd done was retweet it and I
told this said I didn't write that high
that it's a yeah but you retweeted it
which means that you are you are
spreading hate what was it Limerick I
think he said I remember it he said um
your breasts are made of silicon your
vagina goes nowhere and we can tell the
difference even when you're not there
your hormones are synthetic and let's
just cross this bridge what you are you
stupid man is male priviledge or
something like that yeah
is something that some people may find
insensitive or offensive but it's
certainly not criminal who cares
insensitive I don't care yeah so there's
so much insensitivity all the time
especially on Twitter yeah [ __ ] about
insensitivity yeah when do we get so
thin-skinned that we have to call the
police because somebody's written a song
that somebody else doesn't like and I
happen to have retweeted a something you
said it was a retweet and how the
conversation go from there I said well
that's absolute that complete not a
nonsense a that's that's just that's
just mad but I said no no no it's not we
we have to do it because we've got to
and we've got to take the reports of
hate and very seriously I said but there
wasn't any aid I think now I don't hate
anybody that's just nonsense we took
about eight four says well we've got to
report it as a hate incident is it is a
hate incident has it how can it be a
hate incident when there wasn't any aid
it says that's just the way it is we've
got to respect the victim I said we've
already established there wasn't a
victim who said yeah but that's what we
have to call them we have to call them a
victim because they've reported it
they're hurt by it their feelings are
hurt by it they're very very worried
about that about the trans people in
your organization down there in Ingham
dock they are the victim I said well
who's the victim is it the trans people
but I don't have it in me and doc or is
it the person that's worried about trans
people that I don't have it in Ingham
doc who is the victim
well the complainant is the victim I
said so why don't you call them to
complain and then because of the victim
I said what we've already established
that there is no crime we've already
established that I've no idea who this
person I don't know who this person is
it wasn't directed at then how where is
the hate how can there be a victim well
that's just the wait is that the victim
I said but you you've wrongly ought to
talk to me about my words now this seems
entirely ironic to me because you're
insisting on use of the term victim
which by direct implication makes me
perpetrator it means that I am a
perpetrator so every time you use the
word victim you are calling me a
perpetrator
that can't be right you need to watch
your language and he said I'm very very
sorry but we have to do is because of
the victim so we got into this endless
endless loop of utter nonsense
and then I started talking to him and I
said look I don't hate anybody seriously
I'm involved in a political debate
there's the reform to the proposed
reform to the GRA going through right
now the government have called upon us
to talk about this subject so I'm
talking about it and I'm using sarcasm
I'm using bouncer I'm using fairly
fairly aggressive language occasionally
like you word [ __ ] more [ __ ] or what
have you but it's not directed at
anybody and it's just it's just put in
it they said well yeah doesn't make any
difference because you just got to be
very careful about what you say I said
no I'm not going to be careful about
what I say because unless I've committed
a crime then you can go screw yourself
because I am NOT gonna take it selling
off from a two-bit police officer who's
trying to stop me expressing my freedom
of expression I'm just not gonna I'm not
gonna do it unless you can tell me what
I've done wrong go do one and then we
debate a little bit more and then sort
of as a plea I think to my own the
angels of my better nature he said to me
what you've got to understand mr. Miller
is this sometimes in the womb a female
brain accidentally grows the wrong body
parts and that's what being trans is I
when you have got to be [ __ ] kidding
me
they said yeah you have lunch on the
course I said well I just can't believe
it I am I cannot believe that there's a
police officer as dumb as you ringing
the orb going on about lady brains and
penises and telling me to check my
thinking I said I think we're just gonna
end this conversation now and you may
you can go wash e socks and I put
I mean then I went on Twitter and
related this conversation because whilst
I knew instinctively that there was
something very wrong with it I wasn't
certain what it was I knew it was
something to do with free expression I
wasn't quite certain it's been a long
time since I was in the police so I
wasn't certain whether or not they'd
been some new legislation passed and in
actual fact I was doing something wrong
and so I went onto Twitter recounted the
story and then I discovered very quickly
that my instinct that it was wrong is
actually enshrined in article 10 of the
European Convention of Human Rights and
that says that I have the right to
freedom of expression and the police
have no right to try and interfere with
me or limits that freedom of expression
so at this point I had some solid ground
to work from the entire world it seemed
at the time went crazy over this this
threat of tweets that I'd I put up about
thoughtcrime etc it was quite funny
because everybody bombarded Humberside
at home Babbitt with limericks but
fairly serious erm short video of some
guy robbing a liquor store or something
like that and said help us find you can
anybody help us find this man and they
were just inundated how dare you
misgender report yourself a crime report
yourself fake speech and then he was all
done in glorious Limerick form in actual
fact which was quite amusing I tried to
sort it out by getting hold of VM local
PCC and saying look I think that your
guys have gone a little bit too far is
there any chance that we can have a
sit-down chat and we can work work this
out because it's all gone too far I'm
very Pro police I don't like the
embarrassment that that I'm causing you
and can we talk about it and in brave
and stunning fashion the PCC blocked me
and not just blocked me but blocked
everybody else that tried to contact
homicide police to talk about it
so look North came and did an interview
with me and I remember saying that this
is all entirely wrong and I'm going to
take it further and I'm going to go for
the Home Secretary
I'm coming director I'm not blaming PC
Gul I blame the Home Secretary for
thought on this I was kind of mr. mark
actually when he blamed the Home
Secretary it turned out that the first
night I needed blame was the college of
policing so we worked all that out and
we wrote to we wrote to the police and
said we need a meeting we've got to sort
this out
well unfortunately the assistant Chief
Constable went on published I think on
the homicide police website that they
were in fact in possession of 30
transphobic tweets which were designed
to cause distress to the trans community
and show hatred to the chunk trans
community and they and then the
assistant Chief Constable repeated the
claim that the intervention was
necessary in order to prevent escalation
again no word of what that escalation
might possibly be so I put in a
complaint against the ACC and said you
can't you don't get to say this one the
only tweets I'm aware of is this
so-called Limerick and - you just said
there were 30 where are the other 29 and
they wouldn't give them to me they
wouldn't let me know what the other 29
were I said I want to see them you're
making these statements about 30
transphobic tweets designed to cause
hatred designed to cause upset not not
upset as a unforeseeable or foreseeable
consequence design - I want to see the
evidence and they wouldn't release it
they may be put in a subject access
request and eventually got the tweets in
June I've got Mia yeah you know you know
when you've pissed off your girlfriend
or your wife and she's like well unless
you know what you've done
you know you then there's not going talk
about it all I knew was that I pissed
people off and I'd retweeted a non
Limerick so eventually
I got through via subjects access
requests which by the way they
obfuscated I'd not use the right form
I'm not provided the right data I blah
blah blah all the rest of it I this is
beginning to feel like you've got
something to hide anyway eventually
eventually give us the best example time
4:30 but I'm gonna give you I'm gonna
give you some of the best ones right
okay so then tweet number one just had
my son on from Oxford the anti Jenny
Marie crowd are out baying screaming and
spitting at students who went Steve see
Steve Bannon and barricaded their way
that's apparently is hate against the
transgender community okay yeah
absolutely that is hate designed to
cause distress to the transgender
community can do you know why now
because I mentioned Jenny Mori I dare to
mention Jenny Mori and as we all know
the woman's our presenter is a hateful
transpose and because I mentioned Jenny
Mori that is that is evidence number one
tweet number one over the homicide case
against me right that I mention jerry
money
Jenny Mori why then have the temerity to
ask this this trans Day of Remembrance
the thing then like an actual one that
is hate speech that is hate speech
designed to cause distress to the trans
community okay and then and then another
one is I retweet Andrew Gilligan mmm so
again that clear evidence of other hot
of eight this is a good one this is a
picture of Bruce Jenner and I put via
Twitter given your rules on dead naming
could you please clarify who won gold at
the 1976 that is clear evidence of hate
hate so bad
it requires P Seagal to go to my
workplace to ring me up to have a 34
minute conversation where he lectures me
on thoughts and lady brains and all the
rest of it
where it enough to prompt the Assistant
Chief Constable to publish a statement
saying that I'm a dangerous Transpo all
rest of it okay because I dare to ask
that question there's an even better one
there's an even better one yeah and a
lot of this is redacted so I don't know
sometimes what it is but I'm supposed to
said what I say oh here it is
her question mark what the [ __ ] so what
I'm saying what is that in response to
him well I have no idea because it's
been redacted this would be a really
great competition wouldn't it what could
that possibly say in there where where
her yeah question mark becomes hate now
there is only one answer to that and
that is if in that box it says everybody
that hates trans people say her yeah who
says that then yeah guilty as charged I
don't I don't remember it saying that
actually so I'm going tell sure how how
her which I think he's defined as a
quizzical expression expressing doubt
yeah I'm a real loss how heard is is
hate speech this doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense to me I couldn't make any
sense I need this whole thing like you
gets even better so there are thirty of
these and they're all like that okay
hands up there are one or two where I
call dr. Adrian Harrop a bit of a [ __ ]
and I think I probably call that woman
in Canada who's offered transient
children a bit of a [ __ ] jessica Yaniv
no no he's a [ __ ] they weren't the ones
that said it's hurt yeah yeah
daring daring to quizzically question
the idea of the whole trans doctrine is
hate speech it is hate speech according
to both homicide police
and the college of policing okay now
what we've done is we said [ __ ]
we're not having it when just not having
it so I spot the subjects access request
I got a documentation that that logs my
hate incidents and this is interesting
because it doesn't it's not doesn't say
hate incident at the top it says crime
report at the top and then it says my
name and the details and then it says
offense trans hate speech and then you
look further further down and the
category is get this crime non crime so
there is a crutch category of crime non
crime marking offenses on a crime report
and that is something that apparently
I'm not supposed to worry about so okay
it's quite it's early in the morning for
a comedian and this is painful for me
right but so crime non crime what is
crime non crime I will a crime non crime
is when it's a crime but it's not a
crime he schrödinger's crime
I was cloudy I screw both the crime and
a non crime depending on who's looking
at it so so on the one hand versus their
argument so we said you've got to get
rid of that crime report that crime non
crime report we're not having that
against my name get rid of it and they
said no we're not it's purely for
administrative purposes I know it's not
purely for administrative purposes it
because will it appear on an enhanced
DBS check it might our American viewers
and listeners DBS check is when you if
you want to teach or whatever I was say
doing him DEP Security check basically
there are certain professions if you
were to be attempting to be employed in
those professions having tweeted ha and
a bunch of other things you would then
be prevented from working in those
professions potentially a potential
employer would see that you were a
potentially a criminal essentially yes
exactly because even though it's
clusters
hate incident it's on you know your aunt
your dat you're a potential employer
I applied my apply to you you do your
enhance DBS yeah it comes through and
you get the form that says crime report
on it what are you gonna do with that
right you're gonna split you're going to
slim my application into the bin yeah
but you're not gonna you're not gonna
read through and go oh this is fine
because it may be an offense of trans
trans trans hate down here he says crime
non crime so yeah he seems that he seems
ideal let's take it yeah and I said no
you you gotta you can't do them they
said well it won't necessarily happen it
depends on the whim of the Chief
Constable well this gets even crazier
then doesn't it so I've got I've got to
base my future career on the whims of a
Chief Constable not just to keep no it's
not just the Chief Constable is it
depends on the sector that you're
applying truck so ok so let's just say
that I'm applying for a job with a
charity that happens to employ and work
with trans people would that count well
well it might well in that case it's
it's this is a serious thing that isn't
it this is Korea limiting this is proper
Korea limiting and it's a crime non
crime where's the judicial process
where's where's my how do I appeal this
well there is no appeal I wouldn't mean
there's no appeal well because the
College of police guidelines tell us
that we have to log all reports of hate
as hate and give them a hate incident
log on a crime report sure heat
categorizes crime non crime and no
evidence is necessary that's what the
College of Police guidelines say that
there is no evidence of hate necessary
to record a hate crime or incident now
we looked that and said this just is a
travesty it contravenes all notions of
natural justice and actual justice so we
launched our judicial review in the
summer and we said homicide police you
will remove that hate instant against my
name and college of policing you will
get rid of your hate crime guidance
that talks about no evidence is
necessary and we had our two days in
courts three weeks ago and we're now
waiting waiting on the judgment by the
time this comes out there may be a
judgement I think we'll probably have a
judgement next week
okay so yeah it probably will have
happened and we'll make sure to mention
it because a lot of people see freedom
of speech is a right wing issue they
said there's no problem with freedom of
speech in this country you're free to
say what you want and all the rest of it
but what your case is clearly
demonstrated is that if you say
something which goes against what they
want you to say then that could have
very real implications on your career
your earning power all the rest of it oh
absolutely massive and the whole thing
has happened outside of the judicial
process yes because this has not been
debated in Parliament there haven't been
laws passed what's happened is we've got
laws gone through the backdoor so it's a
policy spiral as what's happened and
this has all happened on the back of the
McPherson report and the into the the
death of Stephen Lawrence and Macpherson
does make a link between low-level hate
incidents and serious hate crime and the
logic behind that is tackle the low
level in incident and you you stand a
chance of preventing the serious crime
and the logic to that seems absolutely
absolutely fine now but what the
government have done in 2010 they
representatives with nine protected
characteristics in the equality's act
and so if you are if you are gay if
you're a woman sex is its protected
characteristic being disabled its
characteristic ethnicity ethnicity
protection characteristic yeah holding
GRC or plank savage EIC is a protector
gender recognition recognition
certificate well actually there's
something like a medal you don't like
national transit runs there is a thing
they don't hand out medals or anything
like that no certificate one you just
have to transition first okay just just
to look for anyone who doesn't know my
understanding is essentially that there
are certain things that you can't do
unless you go through the full process
of having your gender recognized with a
certificate okay so it's part of the
process of transitioning lawfully under
the law so that you are treated for the
purposes of the law as the gender that
you are whereas if you were just to say
I'm a woman you wouldn't necessarily
have all the rights that a woman might
have or elsewhere especially and so the
reform to the GRA
is we're trying to take that way yeah
they're trying to size that what happens
so there is no no checks and balances
nothing it's just that you are who you
say yeah as as in fact it was it to
Luciana bird you on the Today programme
a couple weeks ago Nick Robinson said so
okay if I stand here before you and say
I am a woman I'm a woman and they said
if you say so yes absolutely that is one
way to win over female voters in this
election you never know we might wake up
tomorrow winces prime minister yeah yeah
we like we bye
but we've got these nine protected
characteristics or the College of
policing have done they've magically
turned them into five monitored strands
mmm so okay so we've got nine protected
characteristics right pick a card
let's go for number seven not number
seven okay number seven number seven is
your old okay that's not multi-strand so
age is protecting characteristic but you
know the police don't give a [ __ ] about
your ageist insults
picking along okay number four Oh God
yep it's X you pick six sex is a
protected characteristic but it doesn't
figure highly enough for the police to
have it as a monitors round because
apparently women aren't pressing off
okay so they need they're doing really
[ __ ] at the oppression Olympics and
they're just not there just not oppress
enough so it's not enough women killed
for the police to be bothered about
monitoring hate against women so again
trying to lure
sexist jokes are still okay let's go
number two the jackpot because that is
gender identity which instantly isn't a
thing in the Equality Act what it does
appear in the five monitors trans so you
have full protection in all you need to
do is say I am a whatever and apparently
they're on our 100 genders all of which
are protected because you asked for a
definition of transphobia of the police
and they actually said in court just
three weeks ago definitions don't matter
that's what they actually said
definitions don't matter and then they
move the comment conversational so let's
just get this clear what do we mean but
as in scientific definitions of male and
female don't matter or transfer the
definition of transphobia doesn't matter
okay right Randy because no evidence
that would require evidence that would
require some basis in reality and we've
already established that no evidence
whatsoever is required to have a hate
incident brackets transfer
so if I if you say to me that your
identity is smoke you are a smoke
identity or a more modern vape identity
and I say I'm sorry I just don't believe
that
I think that's [ __ ] you can ring up
with the police and you can report me
and no evidence is required no
definition is required you believe that
I'm trans folk bingo I get another hate
incident against my name I just want to
pause for a moment because I feel like
I'm in a dream of some kind yeah me too
this is bizarre yeah this is absolutely
bizarre and a lot of people watching
this will think that this is just
bizarre and yeah what you're talking
about is true and it's the same with
hate incidents against people of
different backgrounds immigrants like me
if I was to say that in the course of
this conversation you'd been rude to me
and that was because I'm an immigrant I
could report that and that would have to
be recorded as a hate incident with no
evidence no investigation no proof yeah
and this is Britain in 2019 I mean this
doesn't make any sense it makes no sense
at all and this is why it's so dangerous
and this is why fair cult have come into
existence to push back against this
nonsense because we see what happens in
we've seen what happens in history and
in other countries and the thing is
totalitarian regimes as a rule don't
come stomping in saying we're a
totalitarian regime they come in
promising freedom and equality and we're
going to free the oppressed and blah
blah blah blah blah but the net result
is the same that you end up with a
totalitarian regime so we're saying it
we've just got to put a stop to this we
are challenging we're calling this out
and then my solicitor when we went to
the directly against the College of
policing we said there are so many
fights in the gender debate that happen
at the top of the Jenga pile and you
know you either win or you lose
but by going for the college of policing
we're going for the bottom junk pile
we're planning on pulling out that
bottom one which gives a kind health
check
of collapsing the whole [ __ ] show and
that's that's what we want to do we want
to collapse the entire [ __ ] show and get
back to the rule of law as opposed to
this policy spiral which is just
captured institution after Institute
have captured the police they've
captured HR departments they've captured
universities they've captured everything
absolutely everything with this gender
nonsense
whereas if you if you refuse to wear
your white pink and blue 1-yard on trans
Day of Remembrance that in itself
becomes possibly a hate instance because
you are not showing positive sports for
a stunning and brave oppressed community
and you get in trouble for it and we're
saying enough is enough this has got to
stop somebody's got to be brave enough
to stand up and call bollocks on all
this and that's what WIC we are fake up
and doing and I can imagine the public
getting quite rightly enraged with it
because essentially being told what to
think and feel but also when you look at
take the example of what's happening in
London but we have a knife crime
epidemic yeah and you think that is what
the police should be concentrating on
well we've just look at my case my case
alone we've had a police constable who
took the trouble to investigate before
they even came to me ring my office come
to my office spend 34 minutes on the
phone 234 minutes on the phone to me
that's a long time an assistant Chief
Constable go in the press and say what
he had to say and then an inspector ring
me up when I was in Australia and give
me another lecture and I remember saying
to him I said look I'm part of the
debates how do I say trans women are not
women without getting into trouble by
the police and he said why would you
want to say that because you know it
upsets people and I said but that's
crazy I can walk down the street and
people are upset all the time if you're
a lever and you see a remain poster
you're upset yeah if election time you
walk down the street if you're a Labour
vote where you see a Tory you're upset I
think we could have said you
why is it you're so bothered about this
one why is that
he said because they are a brave and
stunning community and we have to
protect them at all costs and we're not
saying you can't say trans women are
women but why would you want to now to
me when a police officer says that that
is a form of coercive control and he
just got unlucky
that they came against me because one
I'm an ex-policeman so the whole
mystique about policing has gone - I'm
just not easily I'm not easily bullied
I'm just not easily bullied by anybody
and I have a real interest in law so
when people talking [ __ ] I'm going
to call them out the [ __ ] and that's
what happened here and I said to him I
said look if I if I as a motorist I'm
doing a steady 35 and a 40 zone are you
gonna pull me over in case I s callate
45 and he said to me we can do whatever
we like we're the police that's what he
said
so that is what he said and I said you
actually faces the traffic police can do
whatever they like and I said hold on a
minute that's a massive obfuscation and
you know it you know it that would not
happen and he said well if you don't
like it sewers I said that's the first
sensible thing you've said all day see
you in court and that's then that's how
we ended up at the High Court three
weeks ago let me ask you this as an
ex-policeman one of the coming from
Russia and having traveled a lot around
the world one of the things I've always
thought has been wonderful about this
country is the relation between the
ordinary public and the police it's
tremendous in this country and people
don't realize this because if you
haven't experienced anything else it
seems normal but for example the idea
that you know uh sure you'd walk up to a
policeman to ask for directions it's
unimaginable I once did it I think in in
Prague in Czech Republic with some Czech
friends I walked up to a policeman just
instinctively because I I spent so much
time in this country and I asked for
directions and they all looked at me
like I just gone up to the devil yeah I
know ask for directions we have we in
this country have a fantastic
relationship between the ordinary public
and the police what
you think the impact of that as a next
copy of this on really because I see
people on the internet going all the
time yeah of course the police aren't
investigating crimes they're too busy
talking to some like Herod they out yeah
yeah and you know people who go out
that's just a myth but it's not a myth
they are they are spending their time
she only erodes it erodes trust because
we don't have a police force we have we
have a police service that operates by
consent yes absolutely so we are police
officers are ordinary citizens who've
chosen to give up their time and are
paid accordingly in order to help police
and make the world a better place okay
so it's all done by consent the trouble
here is that the police have been
captured have been ideologically
captured by stonewalled by mermaids and
by a basically by a political ideology
and out of fear of doing the wrong thing
again very much with Macpherson and the
Stephen Lawrence inquiry in mind they've
done what Douglas Mori talked about
which is overcorrect
they've over corrected so they've taken
a they've taken a good lesson and
they've spread it so far that it's now
become a bad lesson and bad practice and
they're also ignorant they don't
understand the difference between policy
and law that has become patently obvious
throughout this entire process because
when you ask them the basis of their
policy what is the legal statutory basis
for the policy they just give you a
policy it's just it's just a an entire
circular argument all the time because
they don't have a legal basis to work
from and they're - so many of them is -
uneducated in law to realize that's what
they're doing and I think even if they
didn't know that's what they were doing
they can't do anything about it because
the the higher echelon of the police
have entirely bought into this nonsense
the higher echelons of the police are
signing pledges to stare
they're havin they're havin rainbow
colors in their senior rank epaulettes
constitutes got some as well good some
rainbow pants anyway rainbow ideological
capture now this is not conspiracy
theory this you just wait until the
judgment comes out yeah from judicial
review because everything I'm telling
you now was said at the judicial review
right absolutely
so Harry let me just get this I mean I I
don't know that much about the police
but my instinct instinctively is that
the police are not generally the kind of
people that would be so massively
obsessed with social justice and all
this kind of stuff
I imagine the ordinary rank-and-file
officers someone who who's you know
already man a woman you know they don't
have this design frankly I'd imagine a
lot of them are fairly conservative
people by nature small see conservative
lawn or all that kind of stuff that's
the kind of people that tend to go into
the police force
so how has that institution been so
thoroughly infiltrated in this way
because again if I can if I can relate
back to Douglas Murray and they've been
taught to forget what they knew
yesterday mmm that's what's happened we
all know the difference between a man
and a woman all of us we all know that
this saying a limerick or saying her or
questioning Caitlyn Jenner and Bruce
Jenner or what-have-you we all know is
not hey but nobody dare admit it they're
all too scared because they've been
captured
they've been ideologically captured by
the groups that are pushing this agenda
which is Stonewall but why do these
groups have so much power because you
know a tiny minority and there's the
it's the rest of the British population
why they why they have it how they have
it I'm not honest I'm not entirely sure
the only thing I can do is when you do a
root cause analysis you get you seem to
get know where people say follow the
money to big farmer and follow the money
to blah blah
kinda but do you watch Game of Thrones
yes okay so I think the real power in
Game of Thrones I don't think is spoiler
is the Lannisters or the Targaryen or or
what-have-you I think the real power is
in the likes of Varys and Littlefinger
yes who are like free-floating radicals
who manage to insinuate into the mighty
houses and because of their knowledge
charm connections or what have you
managed to spread and spread their
message and then I think they're the
ones with the real power and I think it
doesn't take many people many committed
bright people to get into these
organizations and they do it in a Trojan
horse manner so they will come in and
talk about okay with the police remember
how bad you've got it wrong with
Macpherson the Stephen Lawrence oh god
yeah yeah remember how bad you've got it
wrong with the gays oh my god yeah yeah
right okay well we're we are the LGB
organisation right and we can sort out
your policies will sort all that out for
you and there are a fantastic fantastic
yeah what we'll do that yeah well
publicize that you're you you're really
Pro LGB and all this sort of stuff and
pro-pro race and I'll sort it all out
for you let me go in and they write the
document and the first several pages are
great and then towards the back they
stick in a whole bunch of stuff about
gender identity which is not not not
based in law it simply isn't based in
law so you have a policy spiral that is
that has been insinuated into policy and
then you signed off and that's it it's
law by the back door is what it is and
again we have we have proof of this
because we've done a Freedom of
Information requests I've got police
officers in a number of forces who who
work with fair cop and who will log us
into their internet etc and you look at
the documentation and internal
documentation for instance an internal
documentation that says how to treat and
trans prisoners okay so it says a
transcript this is in the met a trans
prisoner has to be searched by the
gender of their choosing their choosing
what if their gender is not available
what about gender isn't there I know
exactly exactly exactly
if smoked gender is not available you're
screwed okay oh let's just taking out
two real basics you've been arrested on
a Saturday night
your hires are flipping Chi they think
you've possibly got a rapid drugs around
your belly I told you this in private
[Music]
we've got a rap with something around
here Belen yeah you're there and you're
in the casa de suite and there's a big
old a big old sergeant who's about to
give you a thorough searching and with
him he's got two female officers as well
all you need to do is say I'm a woman
and the policy says that that sergeant
has to now direct a female officer to
search your bellend and give you an
interview search so what's happening is
there is a facilitation of sexual
assault going on which is why the police
are so up in arms that on that they
don't say because you read the document
it says any questioning of this is
transphobic and all transphobia
there must be seated there must be zero
tolerance to transferor you why because
of Stephen Lawrence because of the
McPherson reports because if you don't
buy the whole thing it means that you're
a racist bastard you know Q hating gay
hating whatever and there's no place for
you in the police force so it's like
somebody's no constant it's a classic
Trojan horse tactic is what's going on
yeah and next year 2020 is when we're
going to be we are fair code we're going
to be challenging this we're going to
have a word with the police and say look
hopefully we've beaten you at once
you really don't want to go to war with
us again can we have a gentlemanly chats
with our lawyers and your people and let
me explain to you how you've been ideal
we captured so that we don't have to
have a big faceoff a judicial review
again list let's see if we can sort it
out that's that's the plan that's the
one
the average copper working in the police
force who are decent people who just
want to go into into the police force
because they believe in it they believe
in law and order they want to help
Society I mean they must be absolutely
outraged by this yeah they're outraged
the pissed off they can't believe it
well they have to do it because their
jobs are on the line because any form of
dissent is evidence de facto evidence of
transphobia and that's why they have
that the hashtag no debate if you see
not on Twitter no debate no if you yeah
if you if you go on the LGBT police
websites which there are hundreds
stonewall any of the trans rights
activists they will often use the
hashtag no debate so it will make a
statement trans women are women
hashtag no debate so the logic behind
that is that if you debated and don't
simply accept it you are a hateful trans
folk and we will not in the same way
that we will not debate racists we will
not debate hateful transphobes
but of course a transfer is somebody who
does not believe in it doesn't go along
hook line and sinker with the I am what
I say I am
well we had the Rose of Dawn the trans
sexual woman who is a youtuber on the
show recently and one of the things she
told us is that trans women like her who
say that biologically despite her
transitions she's still male
biologically has been banned from
Twitter for saying that they themselves
are biologically male yeah that's
exactly that's exactly right yeah that's
exactly right but there's no there is no
debate at all you cannot you cannot
budge an inch from the narrative from
the ideological narrative otherwise
regardless that you're a trans woman
you're a hateful trans woman and you're
not a real trans woman and no debate you
need deep platforming we can't hear your
voice the same with the people that have
be transitioned we don't hear about
details
because it challenges the narrative
there is only one narrative you are born
in the wrong body you know that from an
early age
your lady brain accidentally grew a
penis and it is now society's
responsibility for all of us to correct
that through hormones surgery pronouns
positive reinforcement and hashtag no
debate that's it
and we're saying hashtag screw you so
you see with that I mean I personally my
opinion is that there is such a thing as
gender dysphoria and there are people
who experience I agree but but and there
but there'll be people who don't agree
with that which is all fine I mean it's
the lack of the ability to have the
conversation that scares me yeah and
what you're talking about we know about
this from my interview with the posi
Parker the big tech companies are
enforcing this stuff right we had a
video taken down for hate speech and
then eventually due to a public outcry
was reinstated but fundamentally the big
tech companies are all terrified but
what you're talking about
is the police and I just want to remind
people what the police are there the arm
of the state that is allowed to use
violence yes and imprison people yes
they are enforcing this ideology yes
they are enforcing this ideology which
is why it requires brave outspoken
people to stand up and say this can't
happen it just cannot happen but
somebody has got to stand up and stop
the policy spiral and unfortunately only
way to do that really is through direct
challenge and judicial review which is
incredibly expensive doing this as I put
at risk round about 150 to 200 thousand
pounds to do this that is outside the
possibility of the vast majority of
people to do just that I've got a you
know I've got a business if I can load
it
you are now on yes I mean thankfully
we've had so much support we've got I
think close on six thousand pounds in
the crowd justice fund I've got another
twenty five thousand pounds
twenty-five thousand dollars sorry
pledged in case we lose and it has to go
up to the Supreme Court
so people care people really really care
about this and they care because there
are so many people who agree including
police officers including government
ministers including Lords and they don't
say because their careers are on the
line now again talking about dogs Murray
again he's he talks about how this does
that over most people there is a what he
called a wobbly pyramid yes a very
wobbly hierarchy yeah wobbly hierarchy
pyramid and if you are if you're scared
of that falling down and crushing you
that's very serious because you lose
your job you lose your house you know
you lose your security it's terrifying
and so those of us who are in a position
to stand up and say how did I screw you
and there is a disproportionate
responsibility on us to do that and
that's why you know you asked me
initially why I'm here it's because I
feel a sense of that disproportionate
responsibility and I'm just not the kind
of person to lay down and and take it
from some two-bit police officer and a
two-bit force like Humber beat and
operating on two-bit guidelines issued
by the College of Police
and Harry so this is where we are we've
come to where at the end of 2019 if we
don't stop and if we don't stand up what
do you think will happen are no
predictions are always you know some
pointless but would you think will be
the end game what do you think we all be
in a position where we have a gendered
theocracy where it will be we're
expressing disbelief in gender ideology
will be exactly the same as it as it is
in place like Iran
in the Middle Ages dark ages whatever
where if you don't believe in the
unsubstantiated unscientific
pre-enlightenment claims then you're
guilty the crime and I think your access
to public life will be shut down and
that's already here with this you know
with the enhanced the enhanced DBS check
thing is super super serious we would
say you know you're a you've you've said
something on Twitter that somebody
without any evidence has decided to
report you end up with a hate incident
into your name which can be then
revealed on an enhanced DBS check which
means your career is going nowhere I
find that's the case anyway terrifying
I am whichever side of the debate you're
on if you dance with the devil because
you happen to like the tune today you
need to be very very careful because
that tune is going to change and you're
going to be the one who's going to end
up in the wrong thing clink at some
point and that's why regardless all
right minded people I think need to
sport we are fair cop because we're for
the rule of we're for the rule of law
with the with for the rule of debates we
are post-enlightenment we believe in
science we believe in biology we're
quite happy to debate people with crazy
existential postmodern views you know we
don't hate somebody that thinks a trans
woman is a woman I'd happily sit down
and have have that debate with them and
go I'll have a pint with them afterwards
it's not about hate it's about having
the ability to talk about really
difficult really difficult issues
actually and we should be able to do
that without the police trampling all
over our article ten writes and telling
us that we can't debate in things which
they already concede are entirely legal
to debate about and also we have this
entire issue that is scheduled six I
think it is all scheduled one of the the
Code of Ethics says that the police
must not be political nor can they give
the impression of being political now
when a police officer takes a particular
side during a particular debate which is
heading to you know through Parliament
that is an entire that is an utter
breach of their code of ethics they're
not allowed to do that you cannot you
cannot there's only one thing a police
officer should do when when the debate
gets political a nice to take a massive
whopping public step back and they're
not doing it they've taken aside there
are police forces actively promoting
reform to the GRA
actively actively saying that the old
GRA is outdated and cruel and needs
reform they are acting as though
reformed the GRA has already happened in
other words they are treating gender
identity as being a protected
characteristic in law and it isn't it
isn't and that's dangerous when the
police start acting as a result of crazy
ideological policy spiral we need to
have a sense check and go okay let's go
back to first principles the principle
of law principles of free speech that in
this country on the common law we are
allowed to do and say anything unless
the government specifically tells us
that we can't yeah we are a free people
we're not a bound people and I think we
need to get back to these first
principles and just say hold on a minute
this ain't happening under my watch and
we've got groups all over the country
now springing up and we've got
University challenged professor Kathleen
stock and Rachel aya who are challenging
the no platforming at universities we're
about to launch in the New Year fare
higher education with dr. Louise moody
and the thing that I really want to get
into is the I want to get into Stonewall
and you know Stonewall can do what they
like but I want to break the capture of
Stonewall into the important
institutions which govern all our lives
particularly HR departments because I
look around I was at a restaurant a few
weeks ago a very busy restaurant a lot
around and said you know I was there
with post Parker actually and I said how
many people do you reckon there are in
this room who've been had a knock on the
door from the thought police
and we said probably two with maybe
maybe three there was at least two it
was opposing like there I mean that's a
problem and then I said okay so how many
people do you think there are in this
restaurant who are [ __ ] scared of their
HR departments and we reckoned eighteen
ninety percent of people eighty nine
percent people are [ __ ] scared of their
HR departments because Willie's
transgender day if you don't wear the
pink blue and white land yard show your
support your marked out if you don't
wear your rainbow laces your marked out
if you don't go along entirely with this
absolute nonsense which has no basis in
law whatsoever you're marked out so
that's where we're heading we've got
some big fights before we ask you our
last question how can people help with
what you're doing a welfare cop we have
forgot we need to follow us on Twitter
which is a we are fair cop
go on to the website which is a fair cop
dot org
you can donate followers right to was
eventually will have things like mugs
and t-shirts we haven't got the bit the
minute well yeah just just get in touch
follow us on Twitter brilliant stuff and
the last question that we always ask we
always close our interviews constant
taken away what's the one thing no one
is talking about that we ought to be
talking about I've alluded to it already
but it's how [ __ ] the rainbow is how
absolutely [ __ ] the rainbow is the
rainbow of that rainbow symbol which
used to be a great symbol of hope for
lesbians gays and by people I now equate
it to I think it's so corrupted then I
now equate it to a swastika
well that shouldn't ideology which i
think is insidious dangerous which is
just sweeping through reasons breathe
first breathe out sound you can hear is
the internet going into woods tweed
right and on that no people can't find
you on twitter harry but can they find
you I can see why Facebook Instagram
yeah we can finally I think if they look
for Harry Miller they'll find a they'll
find fair cop finders on Twitter
twitch is the best place really fair cop
on Twitter is it fair cop are taken on
Twitter its we are fair cop perfect
stuff and don't send him any rainbows
all right guys thanks very much for
watching we'll see you in a week from
now with the possibly slightly less
ringing room so could be more triggering
see in a week absolutely thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
youtube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word